a continuación se muestran las gráficas
de la función diferenciable efe y su
derivada f prima vemos la gráfica de fx
en color azul y f prima de x está en
color anaranjado cuál es la
justificación correcta con base en el
cálculo del hecho de que f decrece
cuándo x es mayor a 3 podemos ver que
este es el caso cuando x es mayor a 3
vemos que nuestra función decrece con
respecto a la justificación con base en
el cálculo sin tener que ver las
opciones podemos ver la derivada y va a
decrecer si la pendiente de la recta
tangente es negativa lo que significa
que la derivada también es negativa y
podemos ver que para x mayores a 3 la
derivada es menor a 0 ahora veamos las
opciones f prima de crece cuando x es
mayor a 3 esto no es correcto nos
interesa saber si f prima es positiva o
negativa si f prima es negativa menor a
0 entonces la función es la que decrece
la pendiente de la recta tangente será
negativa
efe prima podría ser positiva aún
mientras disminuye por ejemplo f prima
podría hacer esto aún cuando f prima
disminuye en este ejemplo el valor de la
derivada es positivo lo que en este
escenario significa que la función se
incrementa por lo que descartamos esta
opción para valores de x mayores a 3
conforme aumentan los valores de x
disminuyen los valores de fx esto es
verdadero esta es la definición de que f
disminuye pero no es una justificación
con base en el cálculo por lo que
también descartamos esta opción f prima
es negativa cuando x es mayor a 3 esto
es exactamente lo que escribí aquí
arriba si f prima es negativa entonces
significa que la pendiente de la recta
tangente de nuestra función original efe
irá hacia abajo por lo que nuestra
función va a disminuir esta opción se ve
bien la última opción dice que f prima
de 0 es igual a menos 3 en este punto de
aquí y esto no tiene nada que ver con el
intervalo que nos interesa esta opción
también
descartamos hagamos otro ejemplo la
siguiente gráfica muestra la función g y
su derivada y prima que está en color
azul y su derivada está en color
anaranjado cuál es la justificación
correcta con base en el cálculo del
hecho de que g disminuye cuando x es
igual a menos 3 en la gráfica vemos que
cuando x es igual a menos 3 parece que g
es igual a menos 6 y esto luce como un
punto mínimo relativo cuál es la mejor
justificación nuevamente sin ver las
opciones yo digo que una buena
justificación es que antes de llegar a x
igual a menos 3 nuestra derivada que
hace de esto una justificación con base
en el cálculo es negativa y después de
que x es igual a menos 3 la derivada es
positiva esta sería mi justificación
porque si la derivada es negativa antes
de ese valor significa que la pendiente
va hacia abajo antes de ese valor y si
es positiva después de ese valor
tendremos una pendiente hacia
arriba después de ese valor lo cual es
una buena justificación de que estamos
en un punto mínimo relativo justo aquí
veamos el punto donde x es igual a menos
3 es el punto menor en la gráfica de g
en el intervalo que lo rodea esto es
verdadero pero no es una justificación
con base en el cálculo ni siquiera
tenemos que ver la derivada para hacer
este enunciado así que esta opción no es
correcta que prima tiene un máximo
relativo en 0 3 y en la gráfica vemos
que se prima si tiene un máximo relativo
en 0.3 pero esto no nos dice nada sobre
un mínimo relativo en x igual a menos 3
por lo que tampoco es la opción correcta
que prima de menos 3 es igual a cero
esto nos dice que la pendiente de la
recta tangente de nuestra función es 0
en este punto pero esto por sí solo no
es suficiente para afirmar que tenemos
un mínimo relativo aquí por ejemplo
puedo tener una función que haga esto su
pendiente llegue a 0 ideas
vuelva a aumentar o haga algo así y
después siga decreciendo así que aunque
tengamos un punto donde la pendiente de
la recta tangente sea igual a cero no
significa que tengamos un mínimo
relativo en ese punto descartamos esta
opción que prima cruza el eje x de abajo
hacia arriba de este en x igual a menos
3 en la gráfica vemos que esto es
correcto y coincide justamente con el
argumento que hice al principio vamos
por debajo del eje x ig prima pasa de
negativa a positiva lo que significa que
la pendiente de las rectas tangentes de
los puntos conforme nos acercamos a x
igual a menos 3 pasan de tener una
pendiente hacia abajo a tener una
pendiente hacia arriba que es un
indicador de que estamos en un mínimo
relativo esta es la opción correcta y
con esto terminamos